President Trump goes to the Oval Office
tonight to tell the nation there is a
crisis on the southern border the
president wants more support for a
border wall the government shutdown over
paying for it has left 800,000 federal
workers at risk of losing their
paychecks mr. Trump may declare a
national emergency in order to build a
wall without congressional funding the
defense secretary does have legal
authority to quote undertake military
construction projects not otherwise
authorized by law to support troops
deployed in a national emergency the
Pentagon could only use money from its
military construction budget that has
not been obligated to specific projects
Democrats say they would challenge it in
court but legal experts say that it's
not clear if the courts would rule
against the president in an interview
this morning our major Garrett as device
president Mike Pence about the
president's funding request for the wall
5.7 billion is that negotiable and is
that a down payment or is that all
that's required we believe 5.7 billion
is the proper amount and we laid out a
very specific plan there's no more
funding after that if you get the 5.7
billion no the wall the president's
proposals 5.7 billion to build a steel
barrier on the southern border down the
middle requesting we're also requesting
that would be this year's annual request
payment but beyond that we're requesting
significant increases as Democrats have
asked for in a variety of other areas of
law enforcement of detection
technologies humanitarian and medical
assistance we're at 5.7 billion the
Democrats 11 Democrats in the United
States Senate voted for 1.6 billion and
when we sat down in the Oval Office
after all the cameras left I asked it if
leader Shimer was still at 1.6 billion
and he said no we're at 1.3 billion so
they've actually gone down the president
is there say $2 between that except the
tourism would accept major as you know
we've been engaged in good-faith
negotiations but negotiating is a
two-way street
it's time for the president's
it's time for the Democrats excuse me to
come back to the table tell us what they
need tell us what their offer is and as
the president said we can resolve this
issue in a matter of hours
major Garrett joins us from the White
House major good morning the vice
president said negotiation is a two-way
street sometimes that Street seems empty
is there anything that you took out of
that interview that suggests they're
closer at all not really and the vice
president at one point I asked him Arne
dick Democrats from your vantage point
from the White House vantage point
negotiating in bad faith because the
vice president kept using the phrase
we're offering things in good faith so I
turned it around our Democrats
negotiating in bad faith he said no
they're just not negotiating at all but
when I asked about that 5.7 billion
dollar number it's clear that's not a
negotiable number at least they're not
willing to discuss it in that context
and that it's still a down payment
meaning there's more money this
administration would seek in future
years for more steel barrier or some
kind of wall on the southern border
that's not going to sit well with
Democrats that doesn't appear to me to
be an opening to resolve this might you
tried to get him to answer the question
is the president going to declare a
national emergency right he would not
answer that question on one hand he says
this is a national emergency on the
other hand he says this could take a
year so it just seems why would a
president want anything to take a year
if he thinks it's a national emergency
what do you think he's going to what
audience is he trying to reach tonight I
asked the vice president that I said are
you trying to get hold wavering
Republicans in Congress or are you
trying to reach and persuade entrenched
Democrats and the vice president said
the president will try to reach all the
American public but the reality is the
White House knows that there are
Republicans who are more inclined this
week than last week to pull away from
this debate and vote for some measures
the House Democrats are putting on the
floor to reopen the government the
president is using a televised primetime
address the biggest platform you can
create to hold the line on Republican
defections the vice president has been
making phone calls to keep Republicans
in line the speech tonight is designed
to do precisely that all right major
thank you there will be a CBS News
special report tonight for president
Trump's Oval Office dress and there
be a democratic response the whole
business begins at 9 p.m. Eastern 8:00
central here on CBS